in the foothills of the Andes in
northern Peru there's a remote valley
it's a place still haunted by its past
long ago the people who lived in the
Lambayeque Valley came to believe that
building pyramids was essential to their
survival
they built 250 pyramids one of the most
impressive feats of engineering in the
ancient world a vast valley of monuments
that dominated the landscape but one day
something terrible happened here and the
civilization disappeared along with all
250 pyramids and they were lost to the
outside world for centuries this lost
world lies in the Lambayeque a Valley in
the shadow of the Andes in South America
today there are only hints that this
valley once contained one of the most
impressive collections of pyramids in
the world
these mounds are man-made the remains of
the pyramids they're all built of bricks
over hundreds of years these pyramids
have become heavily eroded and then
vanished
back into the landscape turning into a
series of hills